welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
adding tables so tables show up in a
wide range of places
if you're writing a paper for class and
you're writing a paper on economics or
history there's a good chance you might
need a table
if you're in the fine arts and you're
creating a new web page for
a new play you're putting on you may
want to put up a table of performances
or if you've just created a new
non-profit and you want to put up a
schedule or
a directory of volunteers you're going
to need a table so in this video we're
going to teach you how to put
tables on your web pages so we're going
to use this as our example table
it's uh as you might guess from looking
at it it is the score from uh one of the
big games
stanford 21 cal 3.
now since this is html and everything's
done with
tags as you might guess there's a table
tag
and in addition to table tag there's a
table row tag
and so we're going to enter in our
information by rows
and within each row we're going to
create table data
items or tds there is a
table column tag but you cannot enter in
data by columns you can only enter in
data by rows
the column tag is only used for
formatting and we're not going to cover
it in this lecture
okay so i've got my table i've got a
couple table rows
i've entered my data to my cells am i
done
well it turns out i'm not if we were to
take the
html we've got displayed here and we
were to put it on our web page
instead of getting this nice table on
our left which is our target we're
actually going to get the table on our
right which
doesn't exactly look like a table and so
as you might guess what we need to do is
we need to go in and add
in some cascading style sheet
information
okay so the first thing i need to do is
i need to say that my table
data items should have borders
and so i'm going to give it a one pixel
solid black border
just a reminder when you're working with
borders don't forget that
solid um if you just say one pixel black
it's not going to be enough you have to
say it's solid
and i've given a five pixel padding
which gives me some space between the
words
stanford or california and the
surrounding
borders but
as you can see from the top right that's
what we get with this particular style
we're still not quite there yet that
looks a little bit odd and it turns out
and i'm not sure why they did this but
it turns out that the solution to this
is you need to add in a second rule
specifically on the table and
we need to say that the border collapse
is set to collapse
basically just copy it as written here
and do note that this is on the table
this is not on the table data items
okay so one thing that commonly shows up
on
tables is you have table headings
and then you have standard table entries
and the difference between the headings
and the table entries is the headings
are in bold
and in html they are also centered
so to do this we use the th tag instead
of the td tag you can see i'm using the
th
here both in the style sheet don't
forget you need to have style rules for
the th just like you do for the td
and also in the html
the only difference between a td and a
th is the th has a predefined
setting with bold and centered other
than that the two are basically work the
same
arguably the th is also important
because it does have semantic
information
is for in the web browser that that is
the heading
um and uh you know that could be used
for a variety of different purposes
um including for web browsers that are
reading
to somebody who's visually impaired and
potentially computer programs that are
processing web pages like say the google
search bot might be able to do something
knowing that something is a th instead
of a tv
all right now you may have noticed i've
been using
stanford and california instead of
stanford and cal
and that's because we use stanford and
cal this is what we get
and one can argue that that is the
correct proportions
having stanford nice and big and cal
being small but
it does lead to a rather odd table so
what i'd prefer is something like this
and i can do that just by adding a width
onto the different items
and in fact there's a wide range of
different things that you can do with
the cells meaning the th's and the tds
and so here are some examples of some
changes i've made so i've set vertical
alignment
top and text alignment to left on the
stanford th
i've set cal with the text line to right
overriding the th's center alignment
and then you can see i put heights and
widths on all the cells
all right if we want to get fancier
we've got some other things that we
might run into so here i've got
some data on stanford
geographic origins of the undergrads and
grad students
and if you look at that geographic
origin notice the geographic origin
actually goes across multiple columns
so how do i handle that well there's a
attribute value pair for the html called
column span
or call span and basically i just need
to use that
so here's the source here you can see
that instead of having
three th's for that
geographic origin i have a single th and
i said column span equals to three and
it just goes across all three of the
columns
you may also notice if we go back to
our output here you'll notice that
there's a
line between the empty left-hand top
cell
and the empty cell just below it
and we might want to get rid of that and
we can do that by using
row span so you can think of it as the
problem being that
we have two empty cells one on the top
left and one in the second row on the
left
and so if i can combine those two cells
into a single cell
then i can get rid of that line and so i
can do that using this row span
and here's the source here you can see i
have that th
row span equals 2. notice how
below it in the next row
i start off with th california and so
with th row span equals 2 in the first
row i completely skipped that cell in
the second row
that th row span equals 2 extends across
both the rows i do not list it in the
second row
and i start off with california and if
you look at the image on the top right
you can see i
it does look much nicer all right so
that gives you an idea of how to use
tables on
your web pages in the homeworks you'll
get a chance to play with zebra striping
which can make your
tables look much nicer this is an
example of a zebra stripe table